if you are happy you must be louder the  reason there is so much anxiety in the  system is because the small percentage  of angry and hurt are so much [ __ ]  louder than you we must change the  communication game be the bigger person  I have talked at nausea of the concept  that negativity is louder than  positivity the disconnect between what  is happening in here in conversation to  what's happening on Discord and Twitter  is astonishing and let me tell you  something that has become wildly Crystal  Clear four five six people can be ten  times louder than [ __ ] six thousand  if you are a human being that is lucky  enough to be happy content it is your  responsibility to society and Humanity  to get louder about it unfortunately  most people counter people that are  dropping pain on them with more pain  back and it becomes one big [ __ ] game  of pain ping pong